thanks to curiosity stream for keeping
legal eagle in the air get 26
off curiosity stream and nebula using
the link in the description
last week president trump issued two
executive orders that will ban
two major chinese apps from the american
market the orders state that in 45 days
americans will be prohibited from
carrying out any transactions with tick
tock and his parent company
and from the app wechat this means u.s
companies and individuals will no longer
be permitted to
advertise with the platforms offer them
for download via app stores or enter
into licensing agreements with them
this would effectively stop americans
from accessing tick tock and wechat
the trump orders came as a shock to u.s
consumers who
are generally accustomed to being able
to use any app that's offered on the app
stores run by apple or google and
complicating this narrative president
trump has
not always remained on topic when
discussing the reason for these bans
which ostensibly is national security
president trump also raised eyebrows by
suggesting that if microsoft were to
purchase tick tock thereby
saving it from the ban they ought to pay
the us treasury some kind of fee
because i guess it's china essentially
but more than anything else
i said a very substantial portion of
that price is going to have to come into
the treasury of the united states
because we're making it possible for
this deal to happen wait
what can the president ban a chinese
company through executive order can the
president demand a cut of the proceeds
of that sale
and what's going to happen to your
second favorite video sharing platform
hey legal eagles it's time to think like
a lawyer because the president wants to
ban
tick-tock wechat and tencent and sell
them to
microsoft and get a cut of the sale like
a two-bit gangster
2020 is really weird so let's first
start off by talking about what is
tick-tock and wechat
now full disclosure i'm not on tik-tok
at the moment
i tried to use it once but i found it
baffling and horrifying so i'm obviously
the best person to explain what
tick-tock is
which i'm now going to do so tick
tock is a social media app owned by bite
dance
a tech company based in beijing bite
dance runs a content platform in china
in other areas of the world known as
tauto which i'm probably
incredibly mispronouncing which
translates to headlines
originally headlines was a news
recommendation engine and
now it has evolved into a content
delivery platform reminiscent of
facebook bite dan started tick tock in
2017 when it purchased and repurposed
social media startup musically
and the two video sharing platforms
merged into a global application that
has gained popularity particularly among
teenagers who seem to ditch social media
platforms just as fast as adults
figure out what to do with them now i
asked you on twitter what
tick tock was and your answers were both
illuminating and hilarious
joe vinson said a way of communicating
through shared cultural metaphors
philip gunderson said the sound a clock
makes a lot of you said
it was just vine or vine 2.0 which you
know i get that reference
eric garland said it's like vine except
instead of just sending movies it also
sends your keystrokes on other apps to
the same regime committing economic
espionage every single day
basra said a song by kesha and some
weirdo named hank green
colon a beautifully foolish endeavor is
out exclamation point says
it's a creation engine providing all the
tools inspiration and gratification
necessary all in the same place
now as you probably know tick tock's
popularity surged during the pandemic
the app was downloaded over 623 million
times during the first six months of
2020 and its biggest markets were
india brazil and the united states
although it has received a lot of
scrutiny in
india which takes us to wechat another
one of the companies that's
facing the executive orders wechat is
the most used messaging system
in the world with more than a billion
users the app is owned by the
chinese company tencent which is a major
player in the u.s video games industry
in china almost 99 of smartphone users
use the app wechat is integrated with
just about every aspect of a person's
life from
paying for dinner applying for a loan
watching a video
to ordering a ride share chinese users
can do all of that without
ever exiting the wechat app and people
in the us and other countries also use
wechat to keep in touch with friends and
family in china but wechat has been
linked with chinese state surveillance
and censorship and odds are that if you
send a message to someone using wechat
in china that's critical of the chinese
government then wechat will block that
which takes us to the social data mining
aspects of both tick tock
and wechat tick-tock videos are
obviously
fun if inane but there's also a dark
side to tick-tock as well and the answer
lies in the app's ability to collect
information about its users when you
download tiktok you agree to its data
collection policies
in addition to information you choose to
provide like your identity and billing
info the app
automatically collects other data for
example if you choose to sign up with
your social
media instagram facebook twitter or
google accounts
tiktok reserves the right to harvest
information from those services
including your contact list for these
services and information relating to
your use of the platform in relation to
those services
and then tick tock also collects
information about you from third-party
services like
advertising partners and then there are
provisions like these
quote other users of the platform
sometimes other users of the platform
may provide us information about you
including through customer service
inquiries
other sources we may collect information
about you from other publicly available
sources
and when it comes to tick tock and
wechat the us and other nations are
concerned about the company's
relationship with the chinese government
and what information
tiktok may share although the united
states and other countries trade with
china and corporations do big business
in the country
the chinese government is still
commanded by the chinese communist party
and it's not a free society chinese
citizens don't have freedom of speech
and the government controls the flow of
information
china's 2017 national intelligence law
requires chinese citizens to support the
government's national security
activities
including possibly aiding the country
and seeking intelligence from foreign
countries and their citizens
tick tock's parent company bite dance
has worked with the chinese
communist party to censor and surveil
content that the government did not want
widely known
for example the government cracked down
on any mention of china's repression of
the uyghurs a turkic-speaking ethnic
minority
living mostly in xinjiang which i'm
probably
mispronouncing the uyghurs are muslims
from central asia who are supposed to
have significant autonomy in the
xinjiang
province however the chinese government
is arbitrarily arresting and imprisoning
uyghurs
censoring their language and even
erasing social media posts that mention
the uyghurs by name
and bite dance has helped the government
censor information about the uyghurs in
its headlines platform and on tick tock
users have reported being fed nothing
but propaganda when attempting to
outwit the apps algorithm about the
subject
and naturally this led to concerns the
company would be willing to share data
about its foreign users with the chinese
government
the us army and navy banned service
members from downloading the app to
government-issued phones the us house of
representatives voted to bar the use of
tick-tock on all government-issued
phones
and this isn't necessarily a politically
partisan issue the house vote was 336 in
favor to just 71 opposed
and chuck schumer tweeted his general
agreement with president trump that
tick-tock
may hand over data to the chinese
government and secretary of state mike
pompeo said we urge countries to become
clean countries
so that there are citizens private
information doesn't end up in the hand
of the chinese communist party and that
the app created an opportunity for the
chinese government to spy on
foreign nationals though just because
the app is banned on government phones
isn't really dispositive of the issue
service members are
also prohibited from using fitbits after
fitness data was used to identify
different military installations because
of the gps tracking but tiktok and bite
dance have repeatedly denied ever giving
user data to the chinese communist party
the company claims that all of its u.s
data is stored in data centers in
singapore not under the control of
chinese law
and kevin mayer ceo of tiktok america
also posted a statement promising to
make its data collection process
transparent tick tock also said that the
company has tried to engage with the us
government for over a year but that the
government paid no attention to
facts although bite dance has started
talks with microsoft about simply
selling its u.s platform to the tech
giant
the company also vowed to challenge the
executive orders in the courts
and we'll get to the executive orders in
just a moment but it's probably
worthwhile to point out that there may
be significant first amendment issues
here too because
it's a widely known secret that
president trump really
hates both tick-tock and the content
that's on tick tock
tick tock is a bastion of satire of
president trump people like sarah cooper
who ridicule president trump
by simply repeating what he has said
verbatim looking at tick tock we may be
banning tick tock we may be doing
some other things or a couple of options
and let's not forget about all the k-pop
stands on tick-tock who signed up for
president trump's tulsa rally
i got two tickets but i totally forgot
that i have to pick every individual
piece of land off of my room floor and
made it appear that hundreds of
thousands of people were going to show
up to the rally when
really only a handful of people did
which may have led to the ouster of
trump's campaign manager brad parskal
so it's an open question as to whether
first amendment speech concerns are one
of the reasons why
president trump wants to ban these
particular apps and certainly eyebrows
are raised when the president bans
particular companies as opposed to the
practice of data sharing that is the
thing that is ostensibly objectionable
here
but let's talk about the executive
orders that are at issue here that
effectively ban
tick tock tencent and wechat president
trump's executive orders effectively ban
the use of these apps in the united
states
and to do so these executive orders
invoke the authority under the
international emergency economic powers
act or aipa
and state that additional steps must be
taken to deal with the quote national
emergency posed by these apps
traditionally when presidents used the
aipa act for national security purposes
they rely on traditional issues of
national security such as
access to classified information on
weapons or intelligence systems
but president trump's orders differ in
that they are primarily targeting
companies because of data security and
dated privacy policies
so what do these executive orders say
well let's start with the tick-tock
order which states quote
tik-tok automatically captures vast
swaths of information from its users
including internet and other network
activity information
such as location data and browsing and
search histories
the data collection threatens to allow
the chinese communist party access to
americans personal and proprietary
information
potentially allowing china to track the
locations of federal employees and
contractors
build dossiers of personal information
for blackmail and conduct corporate
espionage
as evidence the ticktock order says the
company censors content in line with
chinese communist party guidelines
the order also says the app could be
used for disinformation campaigns that
benefit the chinese communist party
the order says that quote any
transaction by any person with byte
dance or its subsidiaries tick-tock
will be prohibited in 45 days and this
probably means apple and google will no
longer be able to list the app in their
respective app stores
which takes us to the other executive
order regarding wechat
president trump's order on wechat cited
concern that the app could be used to
spy on chinese nationalists who visit or
immigrate to the united states
the executive order states that the app
allows quote the chinese communist party
a mechanism for keeping tabs on chinese
citizens
who may be enjoying the benefits of a
free society for the first time in their
lives
the order also hits wechat for censoring
the same kind of content as
tiktok now the chinese company tencent
owns wechat
but unlike the executive order on tick
tock which extends to the parent company
bite dance the order appears not to
apply to
subsidiaries of tencent a white house
official told the los angeles times that
the ban
does not apply to tencent subsidiaries
like riot games which is the developer
of the league of legends game which is
very popular on the internet and tencent
also
has a big stake in epic games which
makes fortnite
and the government is clarifying that
those holdings are not affected by this
ban
but needless to say if this order
extends to tencent then it would be a
major disruption for the video game
industry but
for now that crisis appears to have been
averted but if you came here for the
video games i'd highly recommend
checking out richard hogg's channel who
goes into depth about these executive
orders and their effect on the video
game industry i'll put a
link to that down in the description but
here both orders lack
specific details both delegate authority
to the commerce secretary to specify
precisely what transactions are banned
and which might still be
allowed this means that we have to wait
and see what else the government says
about the orders in the coming weeks so
the orders may be broader
or narrower than we think they are at
the moment that'll have to be clarified
but let's talk about the president's
authority to ban tick-tock and wechat
tick-tock teens are pretty upset about
the government's potentially taking away
a platform that they love
so the question is does the government
have the authority to do so
well the answer is generally yes and the
discussion of those powers starts with
the aipa president trump used his powers
under the international emergency
economic powers act
to stop tiktok inside the u.s now the
aipa was passed in 1977
actually to restrict the president's
powers to declare an indefinite
emergency
during peacetime but as with a lot of
legislation that was intended to be a
restriction
it can sometimes be flipped on its head
and allow the executive
broad powers the law here allows a
president to take extraordinary action
without consent of congress but it
requires the president to declare a
national security emergency under the
national emergencies act
and the aipa allows the president to
declare a national emergency to
deal with any unusual or extraordinary
threat which has its source
outside of the united states to the
national security foreign policy or
economy of the united states
now those are obviously extremely broad
powers that give the president
discretion to
investigate block regulate compel or
prohibit the importation
transfer or acquisition of property in
which any foreign country or
national thereof has any interest the
aipa's powers allow the president to act
with respect to any person quote subject
to the jurisdiction of the united states
and to exercise these broad powers the
president merely has to make an initial
declaration of a national security and
justify that declaration to congress
and theoretically initially the
president had an ongoing responsibility
to consult with congress at least once
every six months in order to continue
the national emergency and the aipa
originally gave congress the power to
stop the president from using these
powers if
through a concurrent resolution congress
declares that the emergency is over
however the 11th circuit court of
appeals held that this provision was
unconstitutional now if congress wants
to terminate the president's authority
under an aipa decision
legal experts presume that it would
require passing a veto proof
joint resolution terminating the
national emergency and no such
resolution has
ever passed congress and here the
executive orders rely on a national
emergency declaration made over a year
ago
in may of 2019 specifically executive
order 13-873
that emergency declaration emphasized
the threat associated with foreign-owned
communication and information technology
companies
and services operating in the united
states in circumstances where the
foreign company is subject to the
authority of a quote
foreign adversary so in terms of whether
it's legal the answer is probably
yes as we've seen in a number of
different circumstances
what we have is broad delegated powers
from congress
arguably intended for situations other
than what they're being used for
here but congress hasn't revoked that
power and
when the executive has broad authority
as it does here
it's apt to use that broad authority
congress has the ability to
revoke that authorization but number one
it doesn't appear that congress has the
appetite to do so
and number two it would need to pass
legislation
that would withstand a presidential veto
which
would be a very tall order so you can
see that congress delegated
wide latitude to the president to set
policy using the powers delegated in
aipa
and while congress granted sweeping
powers to the president at least
congress did put
some limits on those powers so let's
talk about some of those exceptions
there are exceptions to aipa that might
apply to the president's executive
orders
aipa is located at 50 usc section 1702
and
subsection b of 1702 states exceptions
to the grant of authority
and specifically it says that the
authority granted to the president by
the section does not include the
authority to regulate
or prohibit directly or indirectly one
any postal telegraphic telephonic
or other personal communication which
does not involve the transfer of
anything of value
and then there's subsection three that
creates an exception for the importation
from any country or the exportation to
any country
whether commercial or otherwise
regardless of format or medium of
transmission of any information
or informational materials including but
not limited to
publications films posters other forms
of media ending with a list that ends
with newswire feeds
so obviously tick tock is going to argue
that these exceptions are directly on
point
and prohibit the president from banning
their company and their practices in the
first instance
the first subsection deals with personal
communications which
tick talk is is nothing if not a way for
people to
deliver personal communications in the
form of short videos to
individuals and groups and then the
third subsection
deals with information transmission
newswires and
informational materials this may apply
to the platform itself but it also may
apply to the practices of tick tock of
taking the information
of its users and customers and
transmitting it to
potentially other places so it's
possible that these exceptions may apply
and
if i were tick-tock i would go before
the courts and i would seek a temporary
restraining order and eventually a
permanent injunction
preventing the president's executive
orders from going into effect
so now the question is can tick-tock do
anything to stop these orders
does tick-tock have any power to ask for
a judicial review of the president's
decision and the answer there is yes
the president's declarations under aipa
are not specifically exempt from
judicial review
but keep in mind that the aipa relates
to foreign affairs and this is an area
where the president has greater
discretion to act
without congress the president's
authority over foreign affairs is rooted
in article 2 of the constitution which
gives the president the ability to make
treaties and appoint
ambassadors other clauses also make the
president the commander-in-chief of the
army and navy
with a whole host of implied powers like
the authority to recognize foreign
governments and
conduct diplomacy with other countries
and as commander-in-chief the president
has many powers involving the collection
of foreign intelligence and use of
military power it would definitely not
be an easy case to win the supreme court
has held that aipa
read in conjunction with the trading
with the enemy act or twea
gives the president wide discretion to
impose embargoes on products from
foreign countries
the supreme court determined that the
aipa was lawfully employed to impose
restrictions on travel into
and trading with cuba lower federal
courts have also upheld the aipa against
first amendment free speech and fifth
amendment due process challenges
and it in fact appears that tick tock is
filing suit npr
is reporting that tick tock is filing
suit against the trump administration
arguing that the us government conducted
no investigation into the company before
levying this ban
and which would uh presumably constitute
some sort of due process violation
because they
were not given any kind of rights before
their company was effectively banned by
executive fiat and tick tock is arguing
that it's being singled out which
seems probably reasonable under the
circumstances it seems that
tick tock and wechat are directly being
singled out as opposed to
other potential companies who are
conducting similar
information gathering practices and i'm
sure that they're going to argue that
the exceptions to aipa
apply and that they fall under the
exceptions and thus
the president doesn't even have the
power to issue the executive orders
which purport to ban tiktok and
as that lawsuit is filed and litigated
we'll see how that turns out
tic toc's best shot at overturning the
decision might be challenging it as an
attack
on the first amendment right of freedom
of speech now the complicating factor is
that the government has gotten
way more leeway to restrict speech since
congress enacted the u.s patriot act
after september 11th and many lawsuits
involving the aipa
and the trading with the enemy act are
also in context of groups associated
with
funding terriers and if tick tock makes
a first amendment case it would need to
claim that the executive order is not
content neutral in other words the
company would need to claim that in
order to explicitly discriminate only
against certain types of speech
or certain speakers but even that would
be an incredibly uphill battle because
the government would just point to data
collection practices and sharing
practices which
are likely to be content neutral in the
sense that all of the data is either
shared or has the possibility of being
shared with the chinese government
and the us government would claim that
that gives it a basis to restrict the
apps and that it's
not related to perceived anti-trump
bias that is contained in the platforms
so while there are challenges available
it seems like the trump administration
has the ability to ban these apps so the
question is would a sale of these apps
save them and allow them to continue to
operate before these executive orders
were handed down microsoft indicated
that it would be interested in acquiring
aspects of tick tock's operations and
allow the app to still be available to
american users but it isn't clear
whether this deal could even work at the
moment microsoft would only be able to
buy a regional portion of the company
that part which operates in the united
states
and the orders would seem to prohibit
microsoft's tick-tock from having
ongoing legal relationships with
tick-tock operations still owned by bike
dance operating in other countries
it could also impact licensing deals for
people who make money on tick tock who
assume that their content is going to be
available
on the other platforms that are owned by
bite dance and the 45 day time frame
here is very short if wechat or tick
tock were to be saved by a sale
the transactions would be very complex
deals like that won't be done within six
weeks although
the commerce secretary presumably could
extend that deadline and here it looks
like tiktok will probably be sold it's
an
external subsidiary so the american
operations are
fairly bifurcated from those operations
in china and the rest of the world
so it's possible to separate it and sell
it cleanly to an american company
but wechat and tencent are different
those companies primarily operate in
china and there doesn't appear to be any
clear way to separate
their u.s operations from the chinese
operations
and in addition even if these companies
are sold to american companies and
continue to operate
we should all be worried about
retaliation by the chinese government
and chinese companies
china has a much longer history of
nationalizing companies than the us does
and it's
entirely possible that china is not
going to take this sitting down it's
possible that
china may force american companies
operating in china to
divest from their holdings in china and
sell those holdings to
a chinese company it's possible as some
have speculated that
china might retaliate by forcing apple
to give up all of its manufacturing arms
in china and sell them to a chinese
company
we don't know what the unintended
consequences of these actions are going
to be
and perhaps the strangest legal question
raised by all of these different issues
is whether president trump can demand
what is effectively a vig
what about president trump's suggestion
that some portion of a sale could be
given to the u.s treasury
really the treasury i guess you would
say of the united states gets
a lot of money yeah here it appears that
president trump was just
spitballing like a mob boss asking for a
vig from a local mom and pop bodega
there doesn't appear to be any law that
would allow the government to take a
percentage of the funds from the sale of
tick tock
you know other than you know taxes the
give me a cut mentality of a sale is
literally the kind of thing that can get
a politician
in trouble for commercial bribery and
that's actually what happened to
illinois governor rod blagojevich
who president trump pardoned earlier
this year now granted that was in the
context of personal gain for the
governor not
funds going to the treasury but also any
kinds of funds
as a sort of key man cut from the sale
would be so small in the context of the
american government that
one wonders why you would even bother
with such a thing
but since there's no evidence or legal
ability for the president to take a
percentage of any sale for himself or
the treasury
it's probably not something that we have
to worry about for now
for now but i have a lot more to say
about the executive orders what's going
to happen to tick-tock and the
suspiciousness of the timing of this ban
but it's probably not safe for youtube
and i can't put them on tick tock
because they're longer than 15 seconds
and also
tick-tock might not exist in a few days
which is why i put my extended
discussion on nebula whether it's the
government shutting down your favorite
meme factory or youtube's algorithm
being capricious it's hard being a
creator when you don't control the
platform which is why my creator friends
and i teamed up to build our own
platform where creators don't need to
worry about demonetization or the
dreaded algorithm
it's called nebula and we're thrilled to
be partnering with curiositystream
and president trump isn't shutting us
down yet
nebula is a place where creators can do
what they do best create it's a place
where we can both house our content ad
free and also experiment with
original content and new series that
probably wouldn't work on youtube
in fact if you liked this episode the
version that i put up on nebula removes
this ad entirely
and replaces it with an extended
discussion of president trump's war
against tiktok
this is not something that started with
the trump administration this goes
back before obama back before w bush
before
bush senior before reagan and actually
now due to popular demand almost all the
videos that i put up on nebula are both
ad-free and have an extended discussion
nebula features lots of youtube's top
educational-ish creators like
our newest additions adam neely charles
cornell and mary spender we're basically
monopolizing music youtube
also we get to collaborate in ways that
wouldn't work on youtube like tom
scott's amazing game show money where he
pits a bunch of famous youtubers against
each other in psychological experiments
where they can
work together or profit individually
it's so
good and i'm working on an original
right now where i explain lots of
misunderstandings about the law called
bad law words good we'll learn important
legal concepts like forced major
racips a loquitur and why hot dogs are
sandwiches
it'll be out really soon so what does
this have to do with curiosity stream
well as the go-to source for the best
documentaries on the internet they love
educational content and creators and we
worked out a deal where if you sign up
for curiosity stream with the link in
the description
not only will you get curiosity stream
but you'll also get a nebulous
subscription for free
and to be clear that nebulous
subscription is not a trial it's free
for as long as you're a curiosity stream
member
and for a limited time curiosity stream
is offering 26
off all of their annual plans and 26
off is by contract the best deal you
will find anywhere
you're welcome that's less than 15 a
year for both curiosity stream and
nebula
and since we've got to stay inside we
might as well be soothed by the voice of
david attenborough or
join chris haddenfield on a road trip
through the universe or just watch tom
scott torture your favorite youtubers
so if you click on the link in the
description you'll get both curiosity
stream and nebula for
26 off or you can go to
curiositystream.com
legaleagle it's a great way to support
the channel and educational content
directly
for just 14.79 per year so just click on
the link in the description or go to
curiositystream.com
legaleagle and of course clicking on
that link really helps out this channel
so what do you think about the executive
orders are they motivated by national
security or political animus
leave your objections in the comments
and check out this playlist over here
with all of my other real law reviews
including covid legal issues and all the
insanity coming out of the trump
administration
so click on this video and i'll see you
in court